la tentation du clown comment un
candidat hors système va bouleverser
l'élection présidentielle or c'est vrai
il y en a plein qui parle de ça qu'ils
disent c'est vrai que là on sait en tout
le monde dit qu'on se dirige vers un
deuxième tour marine le pen et le
président sortant emmanuel macron et y
en a plein d'autres qui disent voilà il
va y avoir quelqu'un qui va sortir du
chapeau et qui va peut-être émergé comme
l'avait fait dans les manuels mâcon
parce que le manuel mâcon quelques mois
avant la présidentielle
il était il n'était pas hyper connue
c'est bien vrai ce n'est pas un des
ministres en plus les plus connus les
plus en vue et il a émergé
voilà après il était déjà dans le régime
politique là vous parlez comme on dit on
n'entre pas entre guillemets 9 de clown
laetitia krupa est avec nous merci des
tisserins voulez vous en parler et
alexis poulin et 8 ans eh ben on savait
quand on a du talent on n'a pas besoin
d'être bien implanté un non mais non
mais non excusez moi parce qu'ils sont
très nombreux et ils ont pris beaucoup
de poids
autant vous dire des choses alors
d'abord je vous propose de regarder
comment l'éthicien croit dur comme fer
que je pourrais être candidat en 2002
elle et c'était sur public sénat on va
revoir des images de vous ouais c'était
chez moi en skype
soyez indulgents s'il vous plaît on
m'attendait pas grave on garder alors il
y en a certains qui ont déjà été
candidat vous le savez jean marie bigard
a fait acte de candidature avant
finalement de se rétracter donc ce n'est
pas une nouveauté mais cyril hanouna
c'est une petite musique qu'on entend
depuis un petit moment et je montre dans
le livre vous le verrez comment le
pouvoir finalement instrumentalise cette
candidature pour en tirer profit vous
verrez comment emmanuel macron tire un
peu les ficelles donc oui il ya beaucoup
non beaucoup de pistes finalement que
j'évoque beaucoup de personnalité que je
teste dans ce livre et vous verrez que
honnêtement ils sont quand même
plusieurs à avoir toutes les chances de
leur côté
alors on va parler de ces personnalités
parce que c'est vrai qu'à didier raoult
eric zemmour jean marie bigard michel
onfray jacqueline moreau eric drew et
francis lalanne
qui pense qu'un clown peut remporter
l'élection présidentielle avant bien sûr
qu'on ait la vie de notre éditorial et
vallées encaissées dans ce cas qu'un
clown entre guillemets peu bousculée
l'élection présidentielle c'est à dire
que tout est effectivement émergé comme
l'avait fait coluche qui avait
embarrassé et on avait été gentiment lui
dire qu'il était temps qu'ils arrêtent
de faire son cinéma parce qu'il
grappiller des voix notamment à la
gauche et que ça commençait à les
embarrasser le scénario peut se
reproduire effectivement il est nourri à
dire oui parce que comment un candidat
hors système va bouleverser l'élection
c'est la tête d'ubs ou pas là mais
l'emporté la question était opportune et
moi je ne réagis pas que ça puisse
remporter en revanche que ça puisse
bousculer oui nicolas pernikoff à moi je
pense que tout est possible après le
terme cloud j'aime pas trop mais
effectivement coluche était même devant
le chien non 1980 dans les sondages
alors si les gens s'en rappellent oui
mais quand même il bouleversé quand même
l'élection
mais pourquoi pas s'il vous avez
quelqu'un qui a des couilles kun
peut-être la journée mais qui a des
vraies convictions ont rappelé tout à
l'heure l'élection d' emmanuel macron
qui n'est pas un coup d'un bien
évidemment mais elle n'était pas du tout
attendu cette élection d' emmanuel
macron vous avez juppé qui se casse la
gueule
fillon qui se casse la gueule et un
moment donné il se retrouve seul sur le
terrain alors pourquoi demain vous
auriez pas un deuxième ou troisième
candidat qui prendrait la tête à la fin
c'est possible tout est possible je
pense alors laetitia c'est quoi un clown
pour vous ouais un clown il faut il faut
défricher parce que je sais à vous avez
raison je veux pas du tout que ce soit
péjoratif et c'est pas du tout péjoratif
en fait c'est une enquête donc c'est pas
laetitia culpa qui vous excédents
qu'elle verse et c'est une enquête j'ai
vu 50 experts des sociologues historiens
des chercheurs des politologues des
hommes politiques des conseillers
d'emmanuel macron des journalistes des
zones de médias comme laurent ruquier
patrick sébastien donc si vous voulez en
fait j'avais une intuition je suis parti
d'un article du monde où il y avait
votre nom inquiétait qui était évoqué
syrine et je me suis dit pourquoi un
conseiller de l'elysée dit lui même
c'est à dire que sa part du pouvoir que
un candidat hors système va se présenter
en 2022 pourquoi il nous dit ça en
citant des noms cyril hanouna mais il y
avait aussi et des élus c'est dans la
liste il y avait aussi didier rahout etc
donc je me suis dit est ce que il est a
déjà une légitimité pour ce type de
question et donc je suis allée bas j'ai
pris mon petit bâton de pèlerin de
reporter et j'ai été enquêtés voyez mais
quand il s'agit de vous cyril à moi je
ne dis pas que vous serez candidat j'ai
dit il ya une petite musique qui est
lancée par l'ailé
c'est depuis deux ans vous savez bien
ombre et a déjà demandé en février 2019
vous avez déjà répondu à jean marc
morandini non je veux pas y aller et ça
continue et c'est drôle parce que et
dans la zone c a beau dire mais non mais
c'est n'importe quoi j'irai pas on
continue je vous assure pas plus tard
qu'il ya un mois j'ai un conseiller qui
m'a encore sorti et 1000 us est donc
c'est bien eux
il s'amuse avec cette hypothèse là alors
clown juste pour dire quoi
clown c'est pas péjoratif séné ses
personnels et flamboyant un candidat
hors système c'est un candidat un peu
sorti du chapeau c'est la outsiders
celui qu'on n'attend pas s'affaisser et
c'est surtout dans mon livre un candidat
qui ne vient pas du tout du système
politique mais parce que les gens
aujourd'hui ne se sentent plus
représentés mais les gens disent que ce
qui ne représente en tout cas le font
mal voilà donc si il n'y a plus de
politique
il faut bien qu'il y ait un autre une
proposition ça viendra de la société
civile donc clown c'est un terme
vraiment qui englobe beaucoup mais c'est
pas du tout les jours à kiffa du tout du
tout du tout du malick sy poulain
éditorialiste politique vous vous n'y
croyez pas de but c'est pas que j'y
crois pas c'est à dire qu'il faudrait
pour qui est alors plus on fait un
candidat hors système un grand mouvement
lincou n'y a pas que ben tout revenir
mais enfin parce que c'est effectivement
une théorie qui arrange les politiques
part ça les fait oublier que c'est un
théâtre de guignol ils sont tous dans un
jeu ils sont tous en train de jouer mais
le maquereau il se déguise tous les
jours un coup il est au delà de notre
dame un coup les avec la bac
un coût etc il met des costumes ils sont
tous en train de mettre des costumes
quand vous les entendez en campagne
c'est des mots creux qui reviennent et
il ya ce problème de leur production
évidemment les français ont l'impression
de ne plus être entendu il ya des amours
l'abstention énorme à chaque vote
donc si un clown doit se présenter doit
être porté par un mouvement alors on va
dire populiste puisque c'est comme ça
qu'on l'a vu en italie avec le mouvement
5 étoiles par exemple et puis elle
précédent trump quelqu'un qui vient de
la télé réalité qui était clown pour nos
anciens qui a donné le catch c'est sûr
qu'à lens a bien su gérer zinio en
italie felinski en ukraine à la guerre
aussi de la télé donc c'est quelque
chose de possible parce que les gens qui
sont populaires comme vous l'êtes
avec cette émission quotidienne il ya
plus de gens qui vous regardent que dans
n'importe quelle partie de france 2 jean
carte et nous est donc vous avez avec
les fans 12,1 partie énorme et si vous
demain vous dites agiles
les gars allez les rails mais chéri on y
va et on va garder politique c'est la
preuve est d'arrêter la pop était
fantastique qu'est ce que ça veut dire
après il court après l'es2 puis je
savais dès le début d' assez qu'on parle
plus de politique aujourd'hui dans le
champ politique moi je le regarde bien
sûr tristitude le reste de champ
politique c'est fait le triste voire
c'est oui oui parce qu'on ne parle plus
de politique on parle d'image on parle
de marketing ça que fait le gouvernement
de la com on paierait que font tous les
politiques de la com et la vème
république et particulièrement
caricatural l'élection présidentielle
c'est théâtre de guignol c'est à dire
que là on arrive ici veut la meilleure
lessive
alors on dit c'est vrai que là lucie
vrai campus et relevant des télévisions
je crois qu'on signe est au coeur de
tout ce processus en fait c'est un
risque énorme
calvillo on se rappelle des différents
débats en d'entre les deux tours à
chaque fois il ya une punchline qui sort
et gagner tel ou tel candidat mais le
mitterrand chirac n'a pas d'odeur à
votre premier lieu celle de hollande
soit président y'a pas que c'est aussi
les guignols le poids des guignols se
voulait en fait tous les observateurs un
peu dit sérieux que je côtoie halle au
beurre de plateau me disent mais non y'a
aucun effet les guignols n'ont pas fait
l'élection
moi je suis désolé sûr je me dis quid
par exemple de l'émission de karine le
marchand pour françois fillon lui même a
dit lui même a dit que c'est un bel lui
avait apporté beaucoup de joie et qu'il
avait remporté les primaires et je veux
vous dire quand emmanuel macron prend
votre micro en 2017
après j'en sais rien je ne sais pas le
poids on peut pas le mesurer mais je me
rappelle très bien et c'est de ce débat
vous êtes là il prend votre micro et
satan là on a libéré à regarder mais
c'est mais c'est un coup de com' génial
franchement vous allez bien
c'est bien passé sur tf1 alors ça c'est
bien passé vous n'avez pas regardé à
puce est en direct en face aujourd'hui
c'est la millième de tpm paix et j'avais
un défi c'est que vous ne souhaitiez pas
un anniversaire avant bien sûr le 7 mai
et cette belle échéance
voilà j'espère alors je vais vous dire
trois choses les oiseaux qui peut
prendre le contrôle de l'émission l'an
iii sur la première je ne vous félicite
pas parce que si vous êtes à la millième
c'est que vous n'avez pas regardé sur
tf1 deuxième chose bon anniversaire
bonne millièmes du temps pour la 1500e
500e ce serait parfait si c'est pas
malheureux fera l'année prochaine mais
il n'est jamais venu ici jamais voilà
mais il va venir c'est en tout cas c'est
le message que le pouvoir envoie mais il
faut comprendre mais moi je comprends
votre intérêt que vous voulez que
voulait receviez et en plus ça permet à
votre public peut-être aussi d'être en
contact avec la peau ni si je vous dire
j'ai des gens qui m'ont dit tu vas mal
de gens qui m'ont dit y'a lexsi
corbières qui est venue cette semaine
oui et voilà que quelqu'un que j'aime
bien un lexique est très sympathique
dans la vie il ya plein de gens qui
m'ont dit tu vois je connaissais mal
alexis corbière il est venu il
intervenir sur napoléon ça n'avait rien
à voir et à plein de gens qui m'ont dit
j'accrochais pas à spécialement avec lui
et je les ai vus sur napoléon et nombre
il est sympa mais envoie il est marrant
il en ajoutant que c'est vrai que
mélenchon a fait une très bonne paie des
policiers aussi sur marlène schiappa
elle est bientôt on va la payer elle y
croyait mais vous savez qu'à deux
longueurs sous pas parce que la lutte
armée en marche leur habitude les
politiques dans certaines émissions
marais chapas un carton d'audience
échappe aux sentiments parfois celle des
traits d'être utilisés c'est ça le
problème
excuse parfois ou dit est-ce que je vais
passer à bien peu trop l'aso où est ce
que je suis un peu pâle à irin
j'ai été comprimé dans leur tpe je pense
que je pense qu'ils ont une avance qui
se servent de moi je me sers 2 bah oui
recommandant le temps ce nom mais aussi
comme trait d'union entre eux les airs
plein de gens qui peuvent pas avoir
accès aux politiciens sur yon plaindre
revendications voyez toutes les semaines
on a des gens qui viennent grevant même
on
ce qui s'est passé sur les étudiants
mine de rien les lignes on a quand même
parlé des étudiants la semaine dernière
ça très vite bouger
on a eu jean michel blanquer au
téléphone ça a bougé derrière et voilà
moi c'est moi c'est ça c'est comme avec
les gilet jaune voilà qu'avec les gilet
jaune avant personne ne les écoute et il
venait sur le plateau ils sont de deux
trois quatre fois et c'est vrai que on a
pu les mettre en contact avec des
décideurs j'ai envie de dire voilà nous
c'est ça moi je veux pas être copains je
vais pas envie d'être copain avec les
politiques je vous dis la vérité
moi le seul truc que j'ai envie c'est de
mettre en contact des gens qui n'ont pas
accès at her trop de repères blick
aurait envie par exemple d'élire un
clown au sens large c'est-à-dire à un
personne personne qui vient du peuple
qui les concours et qui pourrait les
représenter en fait c'est ça moi
j'essaye de vraiment de saisir et tous
les experts que j'ai vu essayer de
répondre à cette question et on n'y
arrive pas mais je vous dirais moi je
suis ronde celui qui équipe qui viendra
et qui va dire moi j'y connais rien en
politique
voilà je vous dis mais je comprends les
différents problèmes des gens et je peux
monter une équipe autour de moi alors
qui sait faire mais moi je sais tranche
et bien c'est ce que le mec qui dira ça
rien qui dira voilà loi je vais venir à
le premier ministre va être je vais
importe quoi françois par mois voilà qui
connaît qui lie entre eux aussi la boîte
ratio exactement mon ministre de
l'économie s'il apporte quoi ça va être
peut-être le patron de carrefour
alexandre bompard voilà il je vais avoir
voilà et qui va dire moi je sais
tranchée mais je ne connais pas du tout
la politique mais je vais avoir autour
de moi des gens nus qui savent
aujourd'hui le vrai tout le travail du
président de la république s'est tranché
aujourd'hui c'est son gouvernement c'est
le premier ministre qui travaillent le
plus en vrai c'est vrai mais quoi qu'il
décide de tout et c'est ça qui décide de
tout mais ils tranchent les autres
propose lui tranche mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya un mec qui sort du sérail et
qui dit moi je sais tranché et je peux
monter une équipe autour de moi et c'est
pas moi que vous allez lire mais
peut-être mois et une équipe autour
peut-être qu'il peut faire la différence
là parce que le fait que vous soyez
trait d'union entre
les citoyens finalement et les
politiques parce que y'a plus de levier
intermédiaires les corps intermédiaires
ont été bousillée par émail mâcon
c'était son choix d'ailleurs la réforme
de l'état
il veut également attaqué les grands
corps d'état alors c'est peut-être une
bonne chose mais une mauvaise l'igas par
exemple l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales va passer à la trappe
ça c'est l'igas qui avait enquêté dans
le sang contaminé bon on va peut-être
avoir besoin d'elle pour enquêter sur ce
qui se passe avec la crise qu'ovide bon
bah là non on aura pu l'igas donc ça
pose des questions et c'est ce manque de
relais entre les politiques qui sont
dans des tours d'ivoire chacun avec des
cours puisque la vème république c'est
une monarchie déguisés et le fait qu'il
va falloir passer avec des choses qu'il
faut remettre en cause aussi les
institutions le fait qu'on ait une
démocratique défaillante c'est des
associations internationales des droits
de l'homme qui le disent qu'on est
finalement un rendez vous tous les cinq
ans pour élire une marque de lessive
alors que derrière on a pas de débat
démocratique et léger léger l'une de
leurs embarcations c'est bien sûr la
démocratie directe
le fait de faire plus démocratie et les
gilet jaune celle et gilet jaune pour la
refaire si on a senti n'avait pas de lit
et ils sont apolitiques les gilet jaune
et ils n'ont pas eu de leader naturel
qui leur est venue à mise en abyme et
ils ont coupé les têtes à chaque fois de
la france a soumis ne sont pas sentis
proches du r n y sont pas sentis proches
de la république reçus mais cyril mais
il ya déjà chèque jacqueline moreau
c'est ça qui est candidat oui et vous
avez raison la recevoir
parce que personne aucun média
traditionnel n'en parle bien celle là
quand même fait acte de candidature avec
une déclaration à l'afp
ce soir elle a pris le chemin
traditionnel pourquoi on ne dit pas que
jacky moreau canton si tous les
candidats lapointe 2022 on oublie
jacqueline moreau est aussi eric drouhin
examiner des pistes camion c'est vrai il
a le droit aussi de choisir la forme
c'est à dire on va parler on va parler
non plus alors imposé dans la fin
d'année candidat que vous avez cité le
que les bombes sont des chansons pâtit
dira où aujourd'hui il a encore une
chance c'est fait un retour est pour
l'instant ceux qui l'envisagent aller
je pense que son ego est suffisant sinon
convaincu par d'autres d'y aller alors
voyez ce que je veux dire en fait ça
sera le bal des ego eric zemmour et eric
zemmour je pense que la petite affaire
là qu'est sorti celui là me rappelle en
fait c'est il ira pas je crois qu'il
adore cette idée là en fait il se refait
avec cette idée là pour aider le
maintenant alors donc l'unique à si je
pense qu'il a des chances parce que cet
espace là qu'il est en train de creuser
c'est à dire à gauche que marine le pen
pour faire un peu rapide un à droite de
l air à gauche de le pen
en fait c'est un espace qu'on n'arrive
pas encore à quantifier regarder ces
news les audiences montrent moins bien
sûr c'est mieux ou pire encore c'est
nous demander ce qu est ce que vous
pensez vous vous êtes un spécialiste des
médias est ce que vous pensez que ça va
monter moi je pense qu'il ya un plafond
pour ce type de public pour senio je
pense qu'on a je pense avant comme
d'anciens encore l'année prochaine avec
mario titre en soit si vous savez à
monter le clown à son média je vais vous
dire je le redis encore monté après et
on dire après ça va dépendre de qui va
être le président si on a un président
voilà si ces six emmanuel macron qui
repasse ça va à mon avis ça va monter
encore parce que justement ça va être
lâché voilà et puis c'est nous
je vous dis c'est nous tous et nous et à
droite c'est moi n'est pas droite sonya
bouquet et voilà l'après-midi et son
émission c'est pas à droite c'est parce
que je n'arrivais zemmour on dit que sa
droite mais c'est pas moi tu vas y a pas
à dire demain tous les plateaux non les
mecs de valeur il ya une semaine après
c'est vrai parce que laurent joffrin
la belgique doit nommer ces sabawi label
gauche parce que sinon on peut pas être
complètement à droite
j'en ai marre aussi coude en tombant
dans le groupe
un bouquin a plus qu'un naples aussi la
droite quelle est l'émission la plus
puissante du groupe canal+ c'est
toujours merveilleux et tpe ont brassé
est tellement c'est ben là où s'arrête
enfin les on est on est au milieu mais
bon voilà
et on n'est pas on n'est pas droite ça
c'est sûr et justin si j'allais quand
y'a quand il ya quelqu'un qui vient
d'une autre chaîne savait ce qu'on leur
dit à chaque fois vous à des chamans
gaucho justement justement série de
votre plat salé pour moi allez pas du
tout comme candidat elle est au
contraire comme organisateur de
candidats et représentants de toute la
france profonde qui cherche justement à
bordeaux parole si je dirais portefaix
donc ce sont des spéciales pour moi
durant l'année prochaine quel soir c'est
la part de tous les
mais non mais justement vous aussi vous
étiez candidat on vous finiriez par être
sur le coup tandis que les gens non mais
voilà de les compteurs de ce pour quoi
les gars se fait des cheveux voilà
justement moi j'ai une question pour
être sacré pas puisque vous disiez que
c'est une sorte de petite musique
pendant tant pour les uns et pour les
autres nouvel amant pour civile et
pourtant si elle n'a cessé de dire qu'il
n'irait pas désiré parfait qu'elle est
quel est l'intérêt que cette petite
musique perdure et qu'on continue à la
faire perdurer et qu'on l'entende encore
à droite et à gauche a inséré à ça et en
fait c'est effectivement un dédié au
monde enquête pourquoi le pouvoir
continue à jouer cette musique parce que
tout bien de pouvoir même élise lucet se
serait christophe castaner corps a
glissé dans un off
son nom vous voyez donc tout vient d'eux
ébranle intéressés alors il est ravi de
la torah band the speech à asphyxier
cloud c'est à dire que en faisant sortir
le ballon d'essai comme on dit le
mouiller on tempête la baudruche voilà
donc on se dit c'est bon on l'asphyxié 2
on va aussi le diaboliser d'une certaine
manière parce que reconnaître leur
existence c'est apparaître comme le
candidat de la raison c'est à dire
qu'être à côté d'un bouffon c'est le
bouffon si le roi c'est ce jeu là qu'ils
aient joué donc être avec cyril hanouna
pardon excusez moi mais vous êtes le
clou en plus j'ai vu que vous
revendiquez d'être clos donc c'est ça
dont je produis emmanuel la choix
raisonné en fait emmanuel macron incarne
la raison à la droiture le sérail la
responsabilité le terrain et c'est donc
il ya sept jeux d'image et il ya aussi
franchement si au passage on peut un peu
siphonner de popularité s'est toujours
donné tout leur talent mais juste c'est
vrai que sur sur ce lit et ce qui va se
passer
ce qu'on se dit tous ces qu'imagine long
qui manuel macron soit réélu l'année
prochaine là emmanuel bach montfrin son
deuxième mandat ce sera le seul
président depuis lé quinquennat à être
réélu parce qu'il pourrait faire qu'il
pourrait faire sien il faut il aurait
fait 10 ans et après il pourra pas être
élu c'est là que ça va être intéressant
et c'est je pense moi dans cinq ans que
l'ajustement il ya beaucoup penser qu'il
va étrenner moi je
l'airé lui cédant cinq ans ça va être un
honnête ne sais pas comment on va sortir
de la crise du tunnel parce qu'on aimait
alors mais qui va est élue si c'est pas
lui alors marine le pen non justement ce
sera ce sera un candidat qui se sera et
merlou d'un cui et qu'il faudra en fait
la théorie est que je ne vais pas
spoiler de jeu beaucoup mais c'est vrai
si moi j'ai une petite intuition après
après deux ans quand kate sait qu'il va
sortir honnêtement dans la toute
dernière ligne droite c'est à dire qu'il
a six semaines pour déposer ses 500
signatures faire franchement 500
signatures c'est plus du tout la mecque
de la politique non je pense que ce sera
un clown qui va sortir vraiment mais ça
peut être un chef d'entreprise ça peut
être
et ça peut être le général de vie y est
ça peut être un militaire on a besoin de
rld ça dépend dans quel état sera le
pays
et pourquoi il va sortir la dernière
minute parce qu'en fait il va justement
éviter tous les débats qui pourraient le
décrédibiliser voiliers qui pourrait le
palais et qui pourraient et donc par
contre il faut bien de la pop les
manuels mac on repassera pas en 2022
pour moi c'est pas ses papiers
ça m'inquiète moi pour moi c'est pas du
tout changement est compliqué mais si ça
sera le seul à repasser et dans 5 ans
avec moi honnêtement à d'autres bordels
parce que tout le monde va venir je peux
prendre la place
il pourra pas se représenter mais c'est
bien tout le problème ce terreau culasse
c'est un bordel la france en ce moment à
peu près partout où il ya la pandémie et
que c'était un monsieur de l'adsa
socialement on fera pas l'économie d'une
grave crise sociale qui inondent le
celaya la dette qui explose et serra
donc la gestion est terrible c'est un
peu importe qui gagne en 2022 le pays va
être dans un sale état et cissé macron
il fera une campagne bkx exactement
comme le clown mais bien qui va arriver
à la fin on aura perdu attendait la
galette je vais tout le monde d'accord
on va faire une nouvelle majorité
présidentielle sociale est rare acuité
une étiquette qui sert à rien et on
verra et au prg le problème c'est qu'une
campagne présidentielle ça coûte de
l'argent
il faut un parti fort militants et il
faut de l'argent c'est ce qu'a fait
macron il avait pas de partie qu'est ce
que ça dit c'est ça dit le niveau
d'informatisation du débat politique en
france c'est à dire qu'on attend le
personnage providentiel tous les cinq
ans et ça au lieu de nous ça s'informer
sur les programmes en 2022 ça veut dire
attention on va continuer en forme des
retraites on va [ __ ] en l'air
l'assurance chômage
vous allez avoir du moins disant social
qu'est ce que vous voulez vivre et
revivre malheureux comment on va s'en
sortir et nous en tant que citoyen on
est dépossédé effectivement pas
en fait vous parliez de bouffon et de
juarez
mais moi pardon mais en fait en cyril je
vois et le bouffon et le roi et non mais
sérieux et il est juste ce qui se passe
sur cette émission c'est incroyable donc
aujourd'hui les vrais politiques
aujourd'hui les vrais politiques ne sont
plus légitimes parce que il ne nous
écoute pas et ne nous entendent pas et
vous et cyril toit en particulier tu
écoutes les gens et ce qui se passe ici
c'est toujours juste et ça fait avancer
les choses le vote doit je pense
dépasser entendu vous voyez ce que je
veux moi je voudrais tourner vers le
côté les médias traditionnels
alors c'est vrai des chevaliers comment
les choses bougeraient autres mois on
n'entend pas assez votre voix et votre
voix est les nombreuses en france 1 hugo
fait c'est comme avec tron quand on
s'est réveillé
on s'est dit mais quelle est cette
amérique mais on l'a pas vu venir
en fait le bouquin c'est juste dire
voilà ça existe écoutez il ya les gens
comme vous écoutez ces français à ce
qu'on espère le lendemain il ya une
chose c'est parfait quelque chose c'est
leur donner la parole parce que le
problème mais oui démocratie défaillante
parce que les médias sont propriété
quand même de milliardaires on a on a
très peu finalement de médias
indépendants qui font les enquêtes on a
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
d' enquêtes des rafales ya médiapart qui
fait le job moi j'ai un petit média le
monde moderne je suis une revue de
presse tous les matins justement de
cette presse des milliardaires et on
voit comment sont traitées on a les a
bernés d'expression ici est-ce que rien
oui malheureusement
mais mes limites et aussi parce qu'un
actionnaire principal il ya une petite
voix qui font qu'on a on fait ce que
l'on ne soit qu' on veut jouer dur
vraiment est assez incroyable et on dit
ce qu'on veut couilles dans la limite du
csa parce qu'il sait sur ce label aux
responsables les politiques évidemment
mais les médias aussi évidemment et la
révolution numérique qui change tout la
tentation du kun laetitia coupant
reviendra sur ce sujet je voulais
d'antibes où les rajoute un bon je
voulais vous demander si un grand
mouvement populaire se lève pour
prolonger ce que dit delphine en début
de l'année prochaine un mouvement
populaire se lève et tous les gens à qui
vous donnez la parole régulièrement
il vous demande vous dis allez salut la
tentation du tout
confirmation
le monde et oui mais si lollipop vous le
demande malheureusement je dois t'en
vous amener avec moi